les urgences sont à bout de souffle les
personnels sont encore aujourd'hui dans
la rue pour vous le redire
il souffre et leur mobilisation ne
faiblit pas tant ils sont découragés
depuis mars l'ensemble des personnels
des urgences se mobilisent pour faire
entendre leur désarroi et il se désole
de ne pas être entendus ils souffrent de
l'hyper spécialisation des lits d'aval
et d'hôpital il souffre d'un sentiment
de solitude et d'abandon exacerbée par
les incivilités et des violences
quotidiennes
c'est une réalité objective les urgences
ne sont pourtant sont pourtant la sphère
et la responsabilité de l'hôpital et pas
seulement des urgentistes qui sont
l'ultime chaînon d'un système de santé
qui n'est plus adapté aux attentes et
aux besoins de la population et le
regroupement à marche forcée des
établissements de santé que vous imposez
ne va faire qu'aggraver la situation
vous n'êtes pas sans ignorer que les
services d'urgence des hôpitaux français
en proie à une crise profonde depuis de
nombreuses années sont aujourd'hui à
bout de souffle il ya douze ans déjà un
rapport de notre haute assemblée les
décrivez comme le miroir grossissant des
dysfonctionnement de l'ensemble de notre
système de santé
madame la ministre que vous aviez
annoncé dès votre prise de fonction
prendre ce problème à bras le corps mais
qu'en est il réellement
force est de constater que la situation
s'aggrave et s'amplifie de jour en jour
face à l'inadéquation entre le nombre de
passages les moyens alloués et la
disponibilité des lits d'aval
malgré les nombreux plans déjà mises en
place ou annoncés on ne peut que
constater leur inefficacité chronique
résultat les personnels de santé d
urgence multiplient les mouvements de
grève sur tout notre territoire
peut-on les blâmer au vu des chiffres et
de la dégradation de leurs conditions de
travail
certainement pas en vingt ans les
urgences ont vu leur fréquentation
doubler nos personnels sont confrontés
chaque jour à la multiplication des
agressions verbales que physiques
car qui dit saturation des services dit
exaspération des patients et épuisement
des personnels soignants qui se sentent
délaissés
il y a urgence madame la ministre pour
nos urgences
pouvant plus attendre car nous parlons
ici de notre bien le plus précieux la
santé des français mais aussi celle de
nos personnels de santé qui n'en peuvent
plus tant physiquement que
psychologiquement les circonstances du
drame sont désormais connus la mère
était totalement démontée mais
lorsqu'ils ont reçu le signal de
détresse relayé par le cross etel
ils ne se sont pas posé de questions ce
sont les mots qu'avec françois de rugy
nous avons entendu des rescapés ils
n'ont pas hésité ils y sont allés parce
que c'est leur mission ils hésitent sont
allés parce que c'est leur raison d'être
et même de mourir malheureusement dans
cette circonstance
depuis que cette terre et battue par la
marée sans fin de la vie est d'abord
tous ceux qui portent secours pour
sauver des vies savent qu'un jour ils
peuvent mourir pour eux rien n'a plus
d'importance que leur devoir et parfois
même le devoir
jusqu'à l'ultime sacrifice le président
de la république a décidé d'honorer ceux
qui sont morts je pense que nous
pourrions aussi honorer ceux qui restent
vivants parce que c'est le même courage
parce que c'est le même équipage la
compétitivité la conquête d'opportunités
de renault ont toujours été au travers
des différents gouvernements une propres
priorités industriel et stratégique pour
notre pays offre un potentiel
rapprochement pour le moins précipitée
avec fiat n'aurait probablement pas
rempli ses objectifs
la proposition de fiat s'appuyait sur
une valorisation au rabais de renault
donne ait les coudées franches à la
famille agnelli dans une gouvernance
d'une nouvelle entité et / de la part de
l'état dans l'actionnariat au delà de ce
deal enterré peut-être aussi
soudainement qu'il a été envisagé je
souhaiterais que vous nous éclaire y est
comment entendons nous nous etat
actionnaire soutenir le groupe renault
pour sortir du blocage actuel et
rétablir un dialogue de qualité
constructif au sein de l'alliance
les consciences s'éveillent selon un
sondage d'opinionway pour 41 % des
votants
je de l'environnement a été décisif pour
leur choix lors des élections
européennes
pourtant votre gouvernement s'apprête à
diminuer significativement les aides à
la conversion et au maintien des
agriculteurs biologiques
en nous alignant sur le label européen
nous avons abandonné des normes qui
protégeait bien plus les consommateurs
et l'environnement
notre modèle favorise désormais les
grandes enseignes au détriment des
petits agriculteurs
il est aussi moins exigeant au niveau
environnemental
l'association 60 millions de
consommateurs a d'ailleurs révélé les
dérives de ce modèle par exemple le lait
les oeufs bio contiennent un grand
nombre de produits polluants
cancérigènes
de même certaines pâtes à tartiner bio
contiennent encore de l'huile de palme
trop d'incohérences nous empêche à
l'heure actuelle de produits réellement
une agriculture saine et positive pour
notre planète
on vous entend souvent dire que
l'écologie n'est ni de droite ni de
gauche
elle ne semble pas en marche pour autant
[Musique]